>> DUNCAN: Hello from Google I/O. My name
is Brandon Duncan and I'm the director of
engineering at LinkedIn.
>> So do you want to talk about what are your
favorite OpenSocial 0.9 features?
>> DUNCAN: Sure. So we recently upgraded to
OpenSocial 0.9 for our container on LinkedIn
and there's lot of interesting new features.
But I think the one that really excites me
the most is data pipelining. This is going
to allow us to create very performant applications
because we're going to be able to provide
the third party partner with exactly the data
that they need to render the view that they're
going to present to the user. We do that all
in one shot so there's not a lot of network
traffic going between our data centers. This
is going to provide our users with the best
experience on our site, hopefully to the point
where they can't tell the difference between
what's natively the LinkedIn website and what's
third party applications being served through
OpenSocial. So LinkedIn is the world's largest
professional networking site. We've been around
for about six years and we have 41 million
members. We recently, in the last year, implemented
an application platform based on OpenSocial
technology. And we've done this because we
want to be able to tap into the wider developer
community so that they can provide our users
with innovative new features as well as we
recognize the fact that professionals in different
geographic locations may want to have features
that tailors specifically to the way they
do business. And this, again, the platform
allows us to take advantage of all these developers
who understand those local markets and can
build professional applications that appeal
to people in those markets.
>> And as developers, what are some of the
worst stories and lessons you learned from
the technical challenge of using your product?
>> DUNCAN: So we've got a lot of interesting
stories. I think one that I won't forget for
a long time is, we actually wanted to make
our--we've been very focused on performance
for our OpenSocial platform and when we initially
launched, we were actually creating the iframes
that hosted the third party applications dynamically
using JavaScript. We wanted to move to more
of a static model, and we did that and we
actually increased performance quite a bit,
but it turned out, the day before we were
about to release this, we realized that it
wasn't working in Internet Explorer. So you
just, you know, reiterated to us the fact
that even today you have to deal with cross
browser compatibility issues, especially with
the technology like OpenSocial which is so
heavily based on JavaScript, which, you know,
there's obviously quirks with the different
browsers. So that definitely taught us, you
know, you don't want to spend three in the
morning, the night before you're releasing
code, trying to debug things and firebug and
using other tools, but, you know, we got through
that. But it definitely made me recognize
that in the future as more browsers start
to leverage, things like HTML5, we're going
to hopefully be able to standardize on a particular
method for doing cross iframe communications,
which is one of the big stumbling blocks,
I guess, I would say in terms of the technology.
>> So on containers, what's your favorite
app on your set?
>> DUNCAN: Yes. So in terms of my favorite
application, I would have to say that that's
the Company Buzz application. I think that's
the only one that I actually use pretty much
every single day. It's really great because
it essentially--it takes all the twits that
people are saying about LinkedIn or any other
company that I might be interested in, and
it gives me that in a nice filtered view so
I can see what are the trends. Are more people
twittering about my company today than yesterday?
Are they positive or negative? And I've actually
found some interesting, you know, uses of
reported bugs, and I've found out about new
features that people want simply by watching
Company Buzz.
>> People are always worried about security.
How are you going to visit your security model?
>> DUNCAN: Well, I think even more so at LinkedIn,
our users are very keen on making sure that
their private data stays private because we've
got people who--they don't want to get spammed
and don't necessarily want to be contacted.
So when we built this application platform,
we were very concerned about, "Does the OpenSocial
standard provide for the rich set of APIs
that we want to provide but at the same time
allow us to control and make sure that partners
aren't abusing our system?" So for us, the
knowledge that partners are going to be authenticating
with us using well-known standards like OAT,
you know, war-tested technologies, and the
fact that the OpenSocial APIs allow us to
provide the partners back with a very granular
set of field. So if a particular user said,
"I don't want my previous companies being
shown on my profile," we can actually hide
that, and so when the developer asks us for
this person's profile, we won't include those.
The standard allows us to do those things.
>> How are the business-caucus users taking
advantage of the social platform?
>> Well, being a professional network, we
certainly--we want to provide the every day
professional with reason to come to LinkedIn,
and to actually get, you know, something valuable
out of it. So take for example the Amazon
book reading application, a lot of people
use Amazon and the type of reviews and information
that you can find about books on Amazon are
really valuable. It helps you make purchasing
decisions as a consumer. But when you combine
that with the social graph that LinkedIn provides
and the information that we know about people,
now you can do really interesting things like,
for example, I might be a software engineer.
It would be very useful for me to know what
are the books that senior software engineers
or architects are reading right now. Or if
I'm in the real estate industry, what are
other real estate professionals are reading.
So rather than just seeing reviews from a
random cross section of the population like
I might see on Amazon, you're actually able
to get more valuable information when you
combine that with the social graph, and OpenSocial
is the technology that allows us to do that.
>> Brandon, we thank you for your time today
and we wish you well.
>> DUNCAN: Sure. Thank you.